- All right, gents.
We all know that when
you're forging a blade,
a nice, rectangular piece of
steel is a good place to start.
But we'd like to make
it more challenging.
So instead, you'll be choosing
the steel that you use
today from this burning barrel.
John, you're up first.
Please choose your steel.
I hope and pray
that I'm going to get
something easy to work with.
Whatever I choose, I hope
I'm familiar with it.
Those are cubes of 1095.
I was excited
that it was 1095.
I was not excited that it was
cubes, shaped like a pyramid.
Your first round challenge
is to forge a hatchet.
Your hatchets must be between 6
and 8 inches from butt to edge,
and your edge must be
between 4 and 6 inches.
Make sure you stick
to those parameters.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your three hours starts now.
We've got four different
types of steel, so
four different configurations.
My first step is to
isolate a single cube,
and then I take
it to the grinder
and start cleaning it up.
I think one of those
little bitty cubes
is going to be enough
steel for a bit.
The high carbon bit is going
to go where the edge will.
I'm going to grab a
rectangle of mild steel.
I'll draw out the mild
steel to form the jacket,
and then insert the bit.
And it's just a simple
forge weld from there.
One hour has elapsed!
That leaves you two hours
remaining to finish your work.
John has a massive chunk of
mild steel over a big bloom.
Yea, John's probably gonna end
up with more steel for his body
than he's going to need.
At first, it's
going pretty well.
Oh, that's ugly.
[groan] Gotta start over.
Things weren't
lining up very well.
I started off with
too much metal,
and then I took some off.
It was still too much.
So I just cut my losses
as quickly as I could,
and started on another piece.
The first one was too big.
This smaller jacket is
going a whole lot better,
but the clock is starting
to catch up with me.
Two hours has elapsed!
You have just 60
minutes remaining.
John's setting his welds.
It was difficult
starting over,
but so far things
are going a lot
smoother than the first time.
10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, shut down your
machines and drop your tools.
This round is over.
All right, bladesmiths.
In this first round
of competition,
you were to make hatchets.
Now it's time for
the judges to take
a closer look at your work.
Aaron, young man,
you're up next.
There is a lot of meat here.
There's going to be a lot
of weight on the shaft.
Your alignment isn't bad, but
you've got a bow right in here.
I'm a little worried about
how long your edge is here.
Yes, sir.
All right, John, you're up.
Please present your
blade to the judges.
Yeah, that's lean.
The shape is really aggressive.
Good fighter.
Not that great on a tool
ax, but but for a thrower,
or a fighter, pretty nice.
It looks solid.
Super sounds solid,
so very well done.
All right, JC, you're up.
Please present your
hatchet to the judges.
I like the overall
size of the eye.
That will allow for
a good size handle.
But with all the mass back
here, none of it up there.
I mean, you drew this down to--
that's less than an
eighth of an inch.
Bladesmiths, at the
end of this round,
each of you was to have
turned in a hatchet head--
an edge that was between
4 and 6 inches in length.
Now, two of you have done that.
Matt, John, you guys will be
moving on to the next round.
Aaron, JC, both of your
edges came up short.
The bladesmith
leaving the forge is--
JC.
Your blade didn't make the cut.
J Neilson is going
to tell you why.
At the end of the
day, there's not
enough material left to be able
to correct the parameter ratio.
And that's why we're
sending you home.
JC, please surrender
your hatchet.